i wonder how to experiment with the mind
without without any medical assistance
first like you know i i pushed my mind
all kinds of directions
i definitely want to i did uh shrooms a
couple of times
i definitely want to uh figure out how i
can experiment with um
with psychedelics i'm talking to rick
dolman i think uh soon
he went back and forth so he does all
these studies on psychedelics
and he keeps ignoring the parts of my
email that asks like how do i
participate in these studies
well there are some legality issues i
mean conversation i won't be very clear
i'm not saying anyone should go out and
do psychedelics
i think that drowsy states and sleep
states are super interesting for
accessing some of these more creative
states of mind hypnosis is something
that my colleague david spiegel
associate chair of psychiatry at
stanford works on where also again
it's a unique state because you have
narrow context so this is
very um kind of tunnel vision and yet
deep really relaxed excuse me deeply
relaxed where
new algorithms if you will can start to
surface
strong state for inducing neural
plasticity and
i think you know so if i had a um i'm
part of a group
um that uh it's called the liminal
collective as a group of people that get
together and talk about
um just wild ideas but they try and
implement
um and it's a it's a really interesting
group some people from
uh military from uh logitech and some
other backgrounds academic backgrounds
and i was asked you know what would be
um if you could create a tool
if you just had a tool like your magic
wand wish for the day what would it be
i thought it would be really interesting
if someone could develop
psychedelics that have on off switches
so you could go into a psychedelic state
very deeply for 10 minutes but you could
launch yourself out of that state and
place yourself into a linear real world
state
very quickly so that you could extract
whatever it was that that happened in
that experience and then go back in if
you wanted because the problem with
psychedelic states and dream states is
that
first of all a lot of the reason people
do them is they're lying
they say they want plasticity and they
want all this stuff they want a peak
experience
yeah inside of an amplified experience
so they're kind of seeking something
unusual
i think we should just be honest about
that because a lot of times they're not
trying to make their brain better
they're just trying to experience
something
really amazing but the problem is
space and time are so unlocked in these
states just like they are in dreams
that you can really end up with a whole
lot of nothing you can have an
amazing amplified experience housed in
an
amplified experience and come out of
that thinking you had
a meaningful experience when you didn't
bring anything back
you didn't bring anything back all you
have is a
fuzzy memory of having a
transformational experience
right but you don't actually have yeah
tools to bring back
all right just sorry actual actually
concrete ideas to bring back
yeah it's interesting you should yeah i
wonder if it's possible to do that with
them
with the mind to to be able to hop back
and forth
i think that's where the real power of
you know
adjusting states is going to be it
probably will be with devices
um i mean maybe it'll be done through
pharmacology it's just that
it's hard to do on off switches in in
human pharmacology that we have them for
animals i mean we
we have you know cree flip recombinases
and we have
um you know channel opsins and
haloredopsins and
um all these kinds of things but to do
that work in humans is tricky but i
think you could do it
with um virtual reality augmented
reality and other devices that bring
more of the somatic experience into it
you